hey guys it's Tuesday August fourth I'm
Mary Kish and you're watching gamespot
news a lot of people have been asking me
where's McDonald's and it's over there
gamescom is currently underway and
Microsoft had their press conference
today here's all the important stuff
that happens scalebound had a gameplay
reveal you can command the dragon and
there's four player co-op halo wars 2 is
happening and they're getting the
developer from total war quantum break
had a gameplay reveal you can stop time
and the release date is april fifth 2016
crackdown has a hundred percent
destructible environments this is what
it looks like they finally showed us
gameplay from Dark Souls 3 this is what
it looks like they announced a chat pad
this is what it looks like finally there
was a fancy custom halo xbox this is
what it looks like next up Game of
Thrones actor Peter Dinklage just got
killed off as the voice actor in destiny
prolific video game voice actor Nolan
North the voice of nathan drake from
uncharted and other games is taking over
Bungie hired north not only to play
ghost in september's taken King
expansion but for the franchise overall
that's right all of Dinklage's voiceover
has been wiped North is re recording
everything the script however remains
the same it's unclear why Bungie elected
to drop dinklage but some fans remarked
that Dinklage's ghost was too monotone
in an interview with Game Informer North
specifically mentions bringing more
personality to the character now I know
I already talked about gamescom but
here's one more microsoft announced more
details about backwards compatibility on
the Xbox one today at Gamescom microsoft
announced that all future xbox 360
titles included with the games with gold
program will work on xbox one by way of
backwards compatibility games with gold
is Microsoft's loyalty program for xbox
live gold subscribers as part of it
subscribers get three games on xbox one
and 360 every month xbox one backwards
compatibility is currently available
only to Xbox preview program members but
will launch for everyone
November there will be more than 100
games available at launch with hundreds
more coming later well that's it for the
news today and I'm gonna go home and go
to bed because involved in here since
6am covering gamescom for the latest in
gamespot news be sure to check back
tomorrow see you then